jonathan faye is the former acting
director of ice
he understands how quickly the
situation's changing on the southern
border he joins us tonight mr marie
thanks so much
for coming on how would you describe the
southern border tonight
well the southern border again to your
point this was
so predictable that we would have this
chaos and they call it a crisis but this
is really
an effectuation of their plan all along
was to have an open border
and to have amnesty and i think you hit
it that made the best point
is the people on the border are the
people that are bearing the cost
but as often with this policy and so
many others the people that
bear the cost that bear the burden of
this the pa
that pay for it never have a seat at the
table to discuss it
it's it's the rich the democrats and the
illegal immigrants are the ones that
decide our immigration policy
the legal immigrants the american people
that pay the cost
in terms of lower wages overcrowded
schools
reduce access to medical care they don't
even have a seat at the table and when
they try to raise their voice
they're they're called names they're
called racists they're called xenophobic
and their concerns are legitimate and
american people are great people and
legal immigrants are great people too
and they deserve a seat at the table
they deserve to be heard on this and so
many of our politicians are afraid to
stand up for them
and are afraid to stand up for our
country and and it is worth noting
that this is illegal to come into our
country illegally which is
is is often lost in this debate
um or discussion entirely
one of my producers said to me today i'm
not sure why we're calling this a crisis
if i offer free hamburgers and a
thousand people show up at my hamburger
stand
that's by design i mean right this is
manufactured
a crisis is when something happens
accidentally the people doing this are
pleased by it aren't they
they're totally pleased by this they
plan for it they campaigned on it i mean
this is the same party that has been
fighting to keep criminals in the
country
through the sanctuary city policy that
has now become a federal policy
so of course this is predictable if you
say you could come to our country
commit crimes even the most serious
crimes and still get to stay what does
that say to people that want to come to
our country it says
we have an open border we have amnesty
because as soon as you get here
you enjoy every right privilege and
benefit that every american citizen
enjoys
you and the american citizens get get
reduced wages
and they bear all the cost and the the
the elites like you talked about the
democratic party and the illegal
immigrants benefit
exactly jonathan faye i appreciate it
coming on thank you so much
thank you